mirroring my recent comments President
Barack Obama urged Democrats yesterday
not to get too confident about Hillary
Clinton's lead over Donald Trump in the
November election polling President
Obama warned that Democrats should
really maintain a sense of urgency all
the way up to november eighth saying
quote if we're not running scared until
the day after the election were going to
be making a grave mistake he said this
by the way to 60 donors at a ten
thousand dollar per person fundraiser on
Martha's Vineyard uh yeah presented
without comment I've been saying this
for a while though right Hillary Clinton
leads Donald Trump in the last 21
consecutive national polls I will show
you a list of some of those poles here
as you will see 21 polls in a row
ranging from I don't know a one-point
lead for Hillary Clinton basically a
statistical tie all the way up to a
15-point lead in a McClatchy marist poll
we also know that electoral dash vote
dot-com has a map based on
state-by-state polling they have the
race currently at 352 to 180 if the
election were held today based on
state-by-state polling they they list
and this is crazy to a lot of people
only Iowa as tied they have both Ohio
and Florida and Pennsylvania and
Virginia and North Carolina and New
Mexico and Arizona and Nevada I mean
they have all of these states at least
somewhat in the Hillary Clinton camp we
know things can change and there's no
reason to think Trump is going to stop
saying insane things anytime soon but he
might and something could happen you
know the types of incidents I'm thinking
of that push this back in the direction
of Donald Trump and I've been saying it
for weeks if you're looking at these
polls is anything more than a snapshot
of where things may be today and as any
reason not to go out and vote in
November do not be swayed by that not to
mention all of the local a lot balance
down ballot hugely important massively
important uh arguably more important
than the presidential race because at
least at that small local level you
might have a
chance at getting someone in office who
is not an establishment candidate who
might want to change the status quo no
doubt so get out there yep do it there's
no reason at all not to vote in November
no matter what the polls say about Trump
versus Clinton and I do worry that
people will become complacent about this
and this is the area where Republicans
really do well they go out there and
they put money and effort and energy
behind City Council's behind uh state
Reps state senators all of these
different levels of government and
that's how you build the ground swell I
completely reject this movement but the
Republicans the right has a movement
where they actually organize to get
right wing pastors elected to local
office the left needs to be doing
something similar not with pastors
unless they're progressive but uh that
this is where I worry and I don't know
uh what about you Jason have you been
talking to people who seem like they're
not that into voting in November for
whatever reason well strangely enough I
am probably of the camp that you
probably the fan of I have never voted a
national election because I oh now i
don't feel like in my lifetime I've seen
a candidate worth voting for we've been
dealing with this issue with Louis four
years where it once took me showing up
at his place with a camera on Election
Day to document him actually voting
because you've been of the same mindset
for a long time and by the way you have
just unleashed an S storm if you know
what I mean in terms of people emailing
in because uh it's still important to
vote in the national elections because
even if I'm not into the whole protest
vote or voting against someone but no
matter what names are on the ballot
there is still a best option and by
least worst we could still say best and
and I still think that that logic for
some people gets them to not vote at all
even down ballot and that's hugely
damaging to progressives and in in the
that specific election you were talking
about we had some hugely important
ballot questions hugely important I
totally forgot not only down ballot but
also the those individual questions that
that often come up including in
Massachusetts the marijuana vote though
coming up well that was uh at the time
this was the other
marijuana but this was the medical one
right and we had that and on the same
ballot was the assisted suicide question
yet it is very very important things
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s